this space how could we possibly make
this space the perfect office and studio
well it requires a lot of trips to Home
Depot
where I first bought these big yellow
tools that presumably were exactly what
I needed to start doing this quickly the
space devolved into chaos it hit rock
bottom on the day when there was just a
giant pile of cabinets appliances
drywall and heaven knows what else all
stacked right here in the middle of this
front room it's moments like these when
you wonder if this is all ever gonna
come together
but then the building starts more Home
Depot and shipments so many ship it so
many boxes there's hardwood floor
there's weird electrical problems that
come up and suddenly you're paying your
electrician way more than you hoped
you'd be paying him but slowly it starts
to come together it starts to look like
the kind of space that you want to be in
work it create in but there's still a
long way to go next comes the visit to a
rug warehouse where a man who came from
Afghanistan 30 years ago shows you a
million rugs then you decide how you'll
cover your floors and will these rugs
actually dampen the acoustics of the
room so we can get good audio I sure
hope so before you know it the owner has
forcibly invited you to his restaurant
that's just right next door where he
gives you piles of steaming kebab and
rice and chickpeas and tea and
beautifully fresh bread and we do love
this food back to work your child is now
sitting on the floor
wait is that asbestos tile it probably
is I should probably get him out of here
scan the internet for the right tile
back to Home Depot the boys are and the
PJs because it's bedtime but for some
reason we have to go to Home Depot I
don't really remember what happens next
I just know that after a million trips
to Home Depot and a million passes on
this place a million tiny details it's
done this is what the place looked like
when we bought it in December and now it
looks like this
[Music]
we wanted a space that didn't feel too
much like a proper studio but rather a
place you would live in spend time in
and while I had some of the vision for
how it would be remodeled and what kind
of countertops we would have is was the
one with the interior design vision she
put a giant effort into collecting a set
of textures and designs that felt that
once natural to us but also interesting
and like a statement the space has all
sorts of textures that mean something to
us like this Pendleton blanket that
comes from our home state of Oregon or
this pillow that we picked up in a
market in Oaxaca Mexico when we were
there in December this beautiful tin
couch was sent to us by article an
online couch company that has also sent
us these stools in this table all of
this providing a unified texture that
feels so natural to the space feels
artful and yet comfortable and all these
textures atop these afghan rugs that we
got from that warehouse all the gear
people who are like hey we came here to
learn about your gear storage and your
studio workflow but I will get to that I
promise but just take a minute to just
revel in the beauty of this room okay so
for all the gear people out there here's
something you're gonna like see these
bars up here on the ceiling this is a
track with a hanging arm that allows us
to mount whatever we need two
microphones light the top-down camera it
can all be mounted right here with the
flexibility to slide back and forth
along this front room this front room is
kind of our primary shooting space we
can shoot here the couch or if we need
to get more of a studio look we can pull
down these seamless --is which give us a
variety of different colors to work with
moving over to the kitchen this is where
you see my pride and joy this giant slab
of walnut butcher block I worked really
hard to get this sucker it came from a
woodworking shop in Illinois and when it
got here it was just a raw piece of wood
and I spent a lot of hours beveling it
and sanding it and oiling it and it's
safe to say that I now have a very
special bond with this piece of wood the
kitchen serves a similar purpose it
allows us to film here but it's a
totally functional kitchen with snacks
and most importantly an iced coffee
Center we use this new setup from fellow
with the stag system and I've really
liked it so far
Irving Farm Zoroastrian cafe in New York
City sent us this beautiful coffee and
we loved it it tastes different than any
other bags we've ever had in the house
and I'm just really glad it exists
ok so beside the kitchen we had this
audio table where we have two mics that
are always set up that USB mics and we
can record voiceovers or podcasts it's
also a place where presumably we could
have a meal and if we ever have guests
who want to work out of the space this
would be their place ok so now into the
office area but first you probably
noticed all these framed photos that we
have around the space these were given
to us by a company called frame bridge
and I have to say this has been one of
my favorite parts of this whole
experience we take a lot of pictures and
usually only see them on computer or
phone screens so to see them in these
giant frames all around the space it's
been incredibly gratifying
it's like art with a memory baked into
it ok now on to the office remember now
it used to look like this with new
paints and floors and a bunch of decor
it now looks like this
[Music]
the anchor to a good workspace is a good
desk and chair setup and for this we are
so so so grateful that we found a
company called fully fully is based out
of our home Portland Oregon and we just
have fallen in love with these desks
they make these sit-stand desks that are
totally solid we have the bamboo Jarvis
desk with this subtle cutout and I have
to say I'm in love they have loads of
accessories like this laptop and monitor
arm or this magnetic hook these file
cabinets along with the desks they send
us these chairs and they look kind of
funky but the whole point of these
chairs is that they get you moving
throughout the day you can sit in a
bunch of different positions which I
found to be really good for my very
fidgety self these desks and chairs have
changed my world they've made my workday
a totally different experience so by the
way I'm gonna plan to make a video
entirely about my working setup and
hacks that I use for a more efficient
day but let's move on to the rest of the
space it is intentionally gave me this
entire wall to myself and I am very very
happy about it and to populate it of
course
I chose my favorite thing in the world
Maps I found this old map on eBay that
was in like an elementary school and
it's been lovely I find myself just
staring at it during the day you also
see more of these frame bridge frames
and some miscellaneous photos from
Switzerland and other travels I'm gonna
keep adding to this gallery and changing
it up okay let's talk about gear finally
gear everyone's here to talk about gear
I'm sure I love pegboards I got these
cheap peg boards at Home Depot and spray
painted them black and this allowed us
to take all of the gear and accessories
and camera stuff out from under our bed
and our children's closet and in every
crevice of our house and put it here it
took a long time to develop a coherent
system to get everything organized and
up on this wall but the payoff has been
huge over here we have this closet with
a charging station that is firm and
permanent it's the first time that I've
ever had any sort of solid permanent
charging station and it's been a dream
come true
SD cards tripods they all have a place
and they're not competing with for
people living in 700 square feet any
longer is of course has her desk and her
wall which is full of gorgeous plants
and knickknacks many of them coming from
our travels so that's our studio it's
been a big investment of time and money
for us but after years of recording
voiceovers under blankets in my bedroom
and stuffing camera gear into our
children's closets were finally
investing in a space that Spurs
creativity and gives us room to make
more stuff with the least amount of
friction possible we're excited about
this place and what it means for our
future and you'll be seeing it a lot
more in our videos I just want to
clarify one thing really quickly in this
video I talked a lot about the products
that we use some of this stuff was sent
to us for free I want to be clear that
all of these items are things that we
actually use and none of the brands that
sent us stuff paid us or told us what to
say they had no control
editorially over what we said about
their product all the stuff that I
bought personally I will leave an Amazon
link for I made sure that all the brands
that sent us stuff we get no kickbacks
if you decide to go buy a fully desk or
an article couch or something from frame
bridge I wanted to make sure that there
was a separation from their influence
and how we talked about them the stuff
that I bought for myself on Amazon that
stuff does support Izzy's channel she
has an affiliate account with Amazon
it's important that I clarify this
because I want you to know that
everything I talked about here was 100%
based on my own evaluation and critique
and usage of these items so thanks for
watching and let me know if you have any
questions about the space
[Music]
you